this is a production of cornell
university when Susan and Tom palomaki
started Lucas greenhouses in 2005 they
didn't want to be tied to routine spray
schedules so they hired Debbie Palumbo
Sanders to help them find a better
gentler way to cope with pests we caught
up with Susan and Debbie at the 2012
Cornell floriculture field day after
they accepted their excellence an IPM
award from the New York State IPM
program my husband Tom and I purchased
the greenhouse and started to read all
the requirements for pesticide
application my husband has a degree from
Cornell and agriculture and we weren't
real familiar with the pesticide
application started reading it all and
really didn't want to have to do that
and we thought there had to be a better
way and there had to be a safer way so
we found dead palumbo sanders who
happens also to be our neighbor go
figure lived right down the street from
us and we hired her and i'll let ya
are they the most important aspect to I
p.m. is that as owners Tom and Susan
were totally open to doing it a better
way because it was the right thing to do
now because it would garner some
publicity or because it was the new
buzzword of the decade but because it
truly was the right thing to do not only
for themselves their workers but for
their customers coming in and because
we're both a grower and a retail
operation under one roof our customers
are walking right through the production
area and when the little kids come in
and want to pick the cherry tomatoes off
the tomato plants we have no qualms
about it and we just smile and they're
happy and that makes us feel a lot
better
if you take a traditional approach to
greenhouse pest management you go in on
a regular basis and you just keep
spraying and in our operation I will go
and scout the whole area and if there's
only 10 square feet with a navy problem
then that's what you would spray would
be the 10 square feet but we stepped
back even further in that we now know
what we're probably going to encounter
from our suppliers to be honest answers
from things blowing you and so that's
what the violence we kind of get one
step ahead of our problem we get the
preventive the Bible trolls that can
take care of your ribs our spider mite
and we're ready for them when they
arrive so they don't build up the
population and we don't have to ni p.m.
yes you may have a little bit of an
explosion of a population in a corner
we're just treat the corner I don't go
through we don't wipe out the whole
greenhouse in a spray program we're very
very conservative in what we apply
and the biggest thing with I p.m. is
that it's a group effort when we first
were introduced to the whole concept of
biologicals into our IPM program we were
introduced to a wonderful grower over in
Buffalo at millers mark Aidan and he
just said call me up if you have
questions just let me know I'll gladly
help you through it and I did and I
called with very simple questions
sometimes I was almost embarrassed
because I felt I was so naive and Mark
would just say no that's right just do
it and we did and i have to say along
the way we stumbled a lot we got very
discouraged but we just kept going ahead
and if it wasn't for the ipm staff that
really helped guide us through a lot of
the problems we encounter because once I
p.m. you have to know what you're trying
to control they helped us with the
diagnosis and understanding the life
cycle about the diseases and the insects
and together it was just a wonderful
experience
it's been great because you know what
our customers are more knowledgeable we
have these wonderful posters that we put
together to explain to them what I p.m.
is and what we're doing and when they
see brand on their plans and what it
means and every single person that
stands there and reads it we know we've
just helped further the education of ipm
and and expanding it so that they know
there are other options for them in
their home garden as well as growers and
they can be more discerning about what
they purchase it's also been great
because our employees all know now at
depth Scouts but when we're full in May
we can't rely just on den we try to
teach we teach them all that you all
have to be looking you all have to be
noticing what's on that plant and if it
looks different what to do
when we explain it to just a home
gardener homeowner who really has no
biology yes you can see the like oh oh
again and if it helps too I mean the
little spots on your leaves of your kale
that you're buying it's okay that's
really what it's all about if there's a
blemish or if they're yeah it's not a
perfect green the customer now goes but
it hasn't been sprayed with anything
that's going to be toxic to me or my kid
you know we have little kids and they do
the tasting tour through the greenhouse
they taste the tomatoes they tasted the
stevia they taste that strawberries and
they can go through a key
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell edu